>> Bret: IT'S FRIDAY.
NOTABLE QUOTABLES.
>> EVEN IF YOU LEAVE THE BOOK,
STILL THINK I'M AN IDIOT, YOU
REALIZE I'M KIND OF AN
HONEST ANY AT.
>> ANY REPUBLICAN SENATOR THAT
HASN'T BEEN CONFLICTED OVER THIS
PRESIDENCY IS PRETTY USELESS.
>> FOUR MONTHS, FIVE MONTHS,
THEY ARE STILL HERE.
>> I'VE BEEN GONE FOR A YEAR,,
AND WE CAN BREAKUP HE CAN'T GET
OVER, HE WAKES UP IN THE MORNING
AND TWEETS AT ME.
>> THUMBS DOWN TO MIKE POMPEO AS
A MIDDLE FINGER TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> HE JUST LEFT NORTH KOREA, HAD
A GREAT MEETING WITH
KIM JONG UN.
IF MEETING WHEN I'M THERE IS NOT
TRUTHFUL, I WILL RESPECTFULLY
LEAVE THE MEETING.
>> "WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, I
DON'T GET CONFUSED."
>> GOD, PUT US ALL ON THAT PLANE
FOR A REASON, NUMBER ONE.
>> IT'S VERY DISAPPOINTING FOR
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PICK HAS
GOTTEN HIS DIRECTION.
>> YOU WANT TO DEPORT AN
UNDOCUMENTED PERSON, START WITH
ME.
>> WE GOT TO TALK TO MY WIFE
ABOUT THAT ONE.
>> WHEN THERE IS A SPEAKER'S
RACE, I AM CERTAINLY TO IT.
>> MORE IMPORTANTLY, DON'T HURT
THE HOUSE.